welcome back we all know the holiday
classic The Nutcracker but Jordan's
studio is putting on The Nutcracker with
a Latin twist at the West Las Vegas
Library and here to tell us all about it
from Jordan Studio we have Jimmy Jordan
and from CCSD we have Brian Zink we have
a full house thank you all so much for
being here all right let's jump right
into it first off tell us about the show
yeah so we uh our dance studio focuses
on ballet and Latin dance so essentially
we decided to put a Twist on the holiday
classic adding some Latin elements to
like spice things up another really good
thing is that our cast is primarily made
up of kids
so we do have some professional adult
dancers to Aid them and the kids are
doing a really good job well we have a
special performance coming up here in a
few minutes but before we get to that
something else really special that you
do is you team up with local
organizations to give back Brian I'll
bring you into the conversation how does
it feel to be part of this it's
fantastic this is the second year that
they partnered with us with us so a
portion of the proceeds from every
ticket sale is going to go be donated to
the Clark County School District Police
Department k-19 like I said well they're
happy about it
it's just wonderful that the some of the
students with nccsd are helping support
the canine team that helps keep it
that's so great we have King and we have
officer Oreo over here and the canines
are happy we're all happy that you guys
are doing this so tell us where is the
show when can people see it King is
ready to go he needs his ticket yeah so
you can uh the show is this Saturday and
Sunday at six o'clock you can get the
tickets at jordansstudios.com general
admission is 35 and I think that's it
well King says get your tickets now I am
so excited to see this The Nutcracker
really is a special special show during
the holidays but I love that you were
putting this Twist on it so I say we
don't wait any longer we have a special
performance waiting across the studio
The Nutcracker with a lot and twists
hash shows on December 17th and 18th all
the information is on your screen at the
West Las Vegas Library and free tickets
and more information just ask King he'll
tell you where to get go we're gonna
turn it over to our special performance
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]